welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about how every
conspiracy theory about trusted
government officials being secret green
skinned aliens is true
and yes this has turned into the daily
fuel.net
oh well maybe we should have led that
way i'm eric voss here with me is marina
mastros how are you doing marina
i'm good how are you eric i i'm doing
all right we're hanging in there
we're making it this may be the way we
all talk to each other in the future and
i'm still not used to it
um i have a question where's philip eric
oh yes thank you for asking because a
lot of you guys have been asking about
this we're sorry that
we did mention this in a previous
episode of rogue theory philip still
works here he's just taking a little
break from being on camera he's focusing
on some cool
uh behind the scenes projects he will be
back on screen he's still our boss he is
he's controlling the amount of o2 i'm
currently getting in this blue dungeon
so um we can't upset him too much he has
a remote
route and office and it has cameras on
eric all the time and he just
dials up and down the oxygen
recording and if i start to get a little
woozy or sleepy it's because he's
dialing down the air just to toy with us
that's his cool off-screen behind the
screen project
oxygen supply
i have too much oxygen
well our opening kind of teased this
whole idea of a
shapeshifters hiding in plain sight so
marina what's our big question this week
okay eric so uh marvel it looks like
it's planning a secret invasion
storyline in phase four right and we've
talked about that but here's the big
question and and i want final answers
okay
okay and if you [ __ ] this up i'm kidding
we're all doomed yeah yeah yeah who
in the mcu is actually a scroll
ah we're back in the scroll search
scroll
search i've been dying
to revisit this question because yeah
i'm so excited for the secret invasion
it seems like
marvel phase four could be headed in
that direction based off of
some clues of nick fury in the scroll
space station
we saw some sword stuff we know sword
factors in what's it well let's let's
talk about the secret invasion comic
event
just to catch everyone up this was the
big 2008 crossover event that was
following civil war
in which marvel just revealed a lot of
characters that we've been knowing for
years and years are skrull imposters
and marina they kind of use that to
explain those characters odd past
behavior yeah used to just call that bad
writing
but no no they're just scrolling
now um it's actually kind of cool it
seemed like a weird idea at the
beginning but the way it played out was
awesome
yeah so elektra gets killed she reverts
to a scroll corpse and everyone freaks
out
like well if a lecturer was a squirrel
who else could be and uh as they're
doing the autopsy on her
there's this coordinated scroll strike
where a ton of characters we thought we
liked
are our bad guys so hank pym attacks
reed richards
he's a squirrel uh dum-dum dugan blows
up the sword space station
oh my god scrawl edwin jarvis activates
this nano virus that corrupts
tony stark's armor and all of earth's
satellite defenses because tony stark is
director of shield at this point
and so shield goes down jarvis scroll
susan storm
of the fantastic four she teleports the
freaking baxter building to the negative
zone
it's awesome how it all happens at once
now this all being orchestrated by
spider woman jessica drew
she is actually the squirrel queen they
they retconned her whole history
and the war plays out you got to read
this comic i i don't want to go like
event by event but
all the characters at some point get
confused for scroll imposters because
there's a huge melee it goes back and
forth
spider-man iron man cap wolverine at
some point there's a scroll version of
everyone
and it's super confusing but it's
awesome now
yes uh we did start to do a scroll
search
series last year marina you remember
uh we made cases for nick fury for carol
danvers
we did one for tony stark that everyone
hated
and people were like there aren't
scrolls i remember we got a lot of heat
for that nick fury one that we did after
captain marvel but then
far from home's freaking post credits
scene ooh
sweet vindication because here we have
at least two major mcu characters have
scroll doubles and that blew the lid
wide oh
the lid was open it was all something
opened
there was a lid and there was a pot and
they weren't together
anymore that's right all of our hair
stood up and
our hats floated to the ceiling when
that happened
uh so yes this appears to be the
breadcrumbs setting up a secret invasion
storyline
but here's the deal we know it's going
to be different because the movies have
painted the scrolls as
friendly allies they're not deceitful
nefarious and evil they're our friends
some of them are
so i'm thinking the way it might go down
is mcu secret invasion
might just be like a panic when humans
on earth start to realize that some
people among them are actually
aliens they freak out and then like the
way human nature always goes they start
detaining them
and that leads to an unwanted war even
though talos is our friend
and people have to kind of pick sites
social a little social commentary
well a little social commentary you
gotta sneak it in there you go
class little cameo this is school this
is school
at the end of the day we gotta learn
gotta learn well let's run through the
full list of surviving marvel characters
we gotta assess witcher scrolls
and we're gonna do this by asking two
questions for each character one
motive why would the squirrels want this
idiot on their team or
like why would they coordinate them as a
double who's benefiting
from that uh and two the evidence right
are there any unexplained
inconsistencies in their histories
or their weird physiologies their
allegiances
any plot holes that you know different
movie screenwriters just you know didn't
share their notes and lead to you know
videos that we do
two days a week on the channel and then
uh
after we go through each character we're
going to give each person a score out of
a scale of one to five and this is what
we want a scroller
a scroller a scroll score
so uh the the rating system that we used
was uh
one scroll safe two screw uncertain
three scroll suspicious four
scroll sidious and then five scrunfirmed
eric how long did it take you to come up
with those far too long
or too long i was like screw this uh uh
squirrels
why isn't one of them scrumptious
because i didn't think of it
okay because that's why uh a teamwork
too
better than one teamwork makes a dream
work and when i'm left alone in the
dungeon
yeah sometimes i don't always get to the
right answer too much time in the
dungeon eric your oxygen
your oxygen okay okay i've got moving
along i'm moving along
this is actually a really good system
that he's got here okay let's quickly
recap the four that we've already
investigated starting with nick fury
okay so the motive he's head of a spy
agency he is a major target who would
benefit
from having a body double right oh my
god like
he was nearly assassinated and winter
soldier so it helps to have you know
another nick fury walking around so yeah
like saddam hussein had multiple saddam
husseins it's it's a good system
and then we know nick fury he wants to
be all places all times eyes everywhere
last time i trusted someone i lost an
eye he wants to keep both
eyes open this is the master of deceit
you're still loud about saddam hussein
trains ran on time
there were no trains there but trains
ran off can i keep going i'll just keep
laughing that's fine
so uh the evidence we saw nick fury turn
into a scroll he was shape-shifting with
taylor's they were working in tandem
and then he was actually on a space
station where the squirrels took his
shoes
so obviously there is uh obvious
coordination
but the question now is how long has
nick fury been a scroll
how many times when we saw him in the
past was he actually a scroll and
yeah the guy faked his own death and
winter soldier that's kind of weird
why would you do it uh and somehow that
fooled natasha romanov and steve rogers
people who have seen their share of dead
bodies and can tell the difference
very strange so there might have been
squirrel involvement in that fake death
uh also why didn't you use carol's pager
earlier you mean to tell me loki's
attack in new york was not
a serious emergency that captain marvel
could have helped out with
right uh so maybe there's like some
scroll involvement with that as a
squirrel he knows that she was somewhere
on some other mission and could not be
taken away from she's
punching galactus in some uh battle
world boxing ring and she cannot be
bothered
right who knows who knows the fact that
we don't know means that the conspiracy
is true
right right of course there's this
detail
where his name is nick fury but people
only call him fury and he says no one
ever calls him nick and that was a big
thing and captain marvel that's how he
knew taylor was a scroll
but people call him nick all the time
throughout the mcu it happens
constantly and i'm not even going to go
through all the all the times that
happens
you could say just over the years he
starts getting more familiar with people
maria hill
and steve rogers he's okay with people
calling him nick but is it a clue
he is also a master manipulator as we
saw with the the coulson
cards in in uh in avengers how he
tricked the avengers into working
together
and there's that uh diagonal toast
detail that's a bunch of [ __ ] that
doesn't count but still
i am going to give him a scroll score of
five out of five
scrun-firmed because we know it at some
point
in his history he had a scroll
doppelganger
so that to me is scruntworth let's move
on to maria hill so she was the other
one in the car with him in the
post-credits scene she is the deputy
director of shield and she would have
all the same reasons as fury to have a
scroll duplicate and she also has a
mysterious background
so here's our evidence you know we saw
her turn into soren and we don't really
know a lot about maria hill's past she's
a relatively recent marvel character
introduced in 2005 in the comics
in the mcu her origin is pretty unclear
she like had a mission in southeast asia
that was mentioned in agents of shield
but she became deputy director of shield
at age
30. good for you which sure good for you
but this is shielded
nick fury worked as a cold war era spy
for years and years and year for decades
of his life and then at around
age 60 he became director of shield so
um maybe she just has white privilege
maybe that is that
maybe it takes a uh yeah a black male
spy working for decades
but a white woman walks in there and
says i was on how i met your mother give
me the job and they're like that's right
or she could be a squirrel who's just
posing as a young woman who's around
age 30. what
so either way we don't know a lot about
maria hill and we don't
know where the real maria hill was in uh
at the
far from home post credits scene so i
give her a score of
four out of five scroll sidious
scroll sidious um i'm gonna i'm gonna
say that
it's just white privilege and she she's
herself she just
gets to the front of the line because
she's white
[Music]
fair enough moving on to tony stark now
this was the controversial scripture
a lot of down votes that like ratio is
was pretty rough
now what's the motive for tony stark
well uh anthony stark
has access to worldwide defenses and
information he has a huge intel network
and you can imagine
a squirrel might want to assimilate as
tony stark to
help the planet earth c53 better defend
itself from
any say cree invasion that might target
it
by helping these terrans build up their
tech and maybe that's why tony stark's
such a brilliant engineer is he's
actually an extraterrestrial
well maybe maybe not maybe not maybe not
well uh what's the evidence well his
body is certainly weird
he had that weird chest cavity where it
went through his sternum in his rib cage
as we saw from pepper pod's deep reach
where how is his chest held together is
it just a metal ring going down there
come on it's just a pot
yeah it's just a pot he's just a pot of
goo the big problem here is we saw him
die
and he did not turn back into a scroll
right so i think we should rate him as
one out of five scroll
safe he still gets one point because
we'll see there's still a chance in the
future secret invasion that a squirrel
might take a dead person's form
this is something you did in the comics
so everyone gets a score of at least
one out of five no one is a zero out of
five but but i agree with that he's he's
scroll safe um and then carol danvers
uh captain marvel her motive well she is
closer with the scrolls than anyone else
that we've seen in the mcu she was last
seen with them leading them to their
next colony
and they scanned her memory so they know
everything about carol danvers history
and you can imagine maybe posing as
their powerful escort
could help scare off enemies like
someone walks up carol danvers in the
bathroom shapeshift into carol danvers
and they're like oh [ __ ] there's that
captain marvel let's go attack another
spaceship
exactly but the evidence is just kind of
this mystery right there's a huge gap in
her timeline
where has she been she really seems more
likely than any other character to play
a huge role in the secret invasion
storyline seems like something that
might be involved in captain marvel 2.
so i think there's kind of a mix here i
feel safe
labeling her as three out of five scroll
suspicious
these words are the best part of this
system it's really just so i could say
these stupid words
i i think that's good because she has
she has a massive amount of time that
she has to explain
herself for so we'll see yeah i went to
law school leave me alone
yeah yeah yeah totally so let's move on
to some of the other characters of the
embassy the surviving characters will be
part of phase four
and we're gonna start with the least
likely scrolls
to the the biggest red flag scroll signs
like these people might actually be
squirrels
it's gonna be really cool if they are um
all right so starting with peter parker
so there's actually a pretty good motive
for peter parker to have a scroll double
identity
because you gotta imagine at the nfr
from home uh he was being outed
as a superhero as a public menace all
nick fury has to do
is uh introduce a scroll enough is
enough
i have had it with these monkey fighting
scrolls to give him
uh an alibi to exonerate peter parker
and say that the person you saw was
actually this
double spider-man and you can say like
look right now we're seeing two
spider-mans at the same time
this poor kid from queens you're just uh
being mean to him it's rude to point
so there's actually a pretty good uh
rationale for the squirrels
we've seen them in the mcu to do this uh
also spider-man's a pretty well-known
hero opposing this him could be very
beneficial for the scroll and yeah this
does happen in the comics the evidence
would be
there's some inconsistencies with peter
like is peter tingle's a bit you know
finicky and far from home we did kind of
find out why but it wasn't very
ever clearly labeled why i would say
uh there's some inconsistency with his
like um
propensity to murder so like he when he
was offered
instant kill in homecoming he's like no
no karen i don't want to do this and
then an end game he's like ah give me
that instant kill back please i want to
keep
all these things that have families
probably i killed them
i killed them all
also there's this fun detail that some
people keep pointing out there's a
possible
talos sighting in the background of his
school in the final scenes of avengers
end game
it guy kind of looks like ben mendelsohn
i don't think it is
but it kind of looks like him uh really
i think the problem is
is i think peter would have been looped
in on any kind of scroll spirity and far
from home
that wouldn't have been hidden from him
right so while he may be
a scroll in the future as we've seen so
far he is not so i'm going to label him
one out of five scroll safe scroll safe
scroll safe
scroll clearly thor so thor is the god
of thunder there's a pretty good motive
there he's a feared galactic warrior
and who wouldn't want to look like chris
hemsworth am i right
it's motivation enough it's like i i
don't want to work out i'm just going to
shape shift into this hunk
now the evidence would be his weight
right so thor got fat
in avengers maybe maybe a scroll
imposter couldn't keep up with the
fitness regimen
i was gonna say so soon just that the
scroll was overweight and then
we're not blaming uh thor for for cargo
loading it was this girl shape-shifter
but the problem is thor is ancient and
he's been a critical point of view
character
so it's like i think it's more likely
for characters that we haven't seen
stories from their point of view
because there's like implied
subjectivity there like we're kind of in
their head
but if they're like periphery characters
we don't know a lot about we haven't
seen a scene from their point of view
those are the ones we got to keep an eye
on
so thor doesn't really fit in that
category also he has the bifrost so like
the scrolls
whole thing in captain marvel they're
trying to build a light speed engine
with the tesseract
if they had the power of the bifrost
they wouldn't need that so i think thor
let's scroll score of one out of five
scroll safe squeeze now let's talk about
the retired steve rogers
so the motive well he also is a
prominent avenger there's lots of
goodwill
people inherently trust steve rogers
also you could say maybe nick fury could
use scroll steve to
do all those media spots that he
recorded for spider-man far from home
like
steve rogers is out of engine around the
world and they just have a double to
to cut some promos how many more of
these uh useful
but it seems a lot of effort uh but
there is some evidence some people say
there's that line it's a war where zemo
goes there's a bit of green in the blue
of your eyes
where steve rogers has just very clearly
blue eyes so was that what
was it someone else i i don't know i
steve rogers pre-dates the scroll
arrival that we know of he was
frozen in ice throughout the 80s and 90s
he wasn't involved with any of that
also he's done he's an old man now they
might try to duplicate him in the future
but i i don't think chris evans is
coming back uh anytime soon
aside from maybe a cameo but i don't
think we're going to reveal that any of
the past times we saw him he was a
scroll so one out of five scroll safe
squishy
[Music]
but let's move on to bucky barnes
because he does have a more complicated
backstory right
so bucky barnes was a winner soldier
someone who was considered a ghost right
he was an assassin who
seemed to appear in multiple places at
the same time no one really knew where
he was
and yeah there are huge gaps in his
history the guy does not age
now yes he did have like a hydra
cocktail of super soldier serum but the
whole point of super soldier serum is
erskine
went to the usa and made a specific
unique formula that worked for steve
rogers
and then maybe zola just kind of like
reverse engineered it but like
it's not really clear what bucky got he
got a form of
of serum we saw the blue bags in civil
war so really
anyone can just have that serum now like
maybe there might be more to it we don't
know
also he appeared to die and then he just
came back but okay
i i i'm still more on the fence with
bucky he
he can recall memories with steve from
their youths in the 20s and 30s or you
mean to tell me that
a scroll assimilated him from the
beginning no so i'm going to say
two out of five screw uncertain when it
comes to bucky parts that's the best
word pun
word play yeah i'm fascinated by his
history but i don't need to see him
um be revealed as a scroll the whole
time i think there's other more
interesting places you can go with this
character but let's talk about hank pym
hank pym is an interesting one he would
have a pretty big motive to be targeted
by the scroll you got to think about it
they wanted hank pym to help expand
terran tech with some bonkers
pseudoscience that makes
no freaking sense maybe because it's
extraterrestrial uh
and he would be at the heart of shield
throughout late 20th century history
the evidence being he is one of the big
scroll reveals in the comics and he is
stubborn and kind of insane
he doesn't seem to give a [ __ ] about
earth's laws or institutions the problem
is he did quit
shield right when the squirrels would
need someone inside shield on the inside
in the late 80s he quit in 87. uh all
the captain marvel stuff was happening
in 89.
so i i score him at two out of five
screw uncertain
screen certain let's quickly talk about
wong
and the other sorcerers so it would be
very useful for the squirrels to have
someone on the inside of the
sorcerer community facebook page right
and wong's a weird one he totally sits
out infinity war
bruce banner's like well i'm gonna keep
fighting in this movie and wong's like
all right i'm gonna defend
this building but he delights in human
food kind of like you know taylors loved
fast food
he loves his tuna melts he loves ben and
jerry's but he does seem to be like
earth-centered like when he shows dr
strange how it all works he just showed
the planet earth he didn't show anything
else in the cosmos
which you would think he would care a
bit more about the cosmos if he was from
another planet so i scored him two out
of five
scrolling certain scriptures all right
uh roadie james rhodes
uh yeah there's a motive here he's the
one who gets tony stark to share his
tech with
like the the public resources with the
world governments
uh and you gotta think like maybe you
could see this girls being like well
there's this brilliant
earth lane but we gotta make sure all of
earth gets access to this weaponry
maybe that's what roadie's mission was
um the big evidence being
he looked like terence howard in one
movie and then don cheadle in the next
boom looking for that yeah
but i don't i don't know uh first scroll
impression
yeah he's not hiding it at all he just
forgot what he was
like he's like now i am i think this is
what don
you look like this guy yeah but at the
end of the day
i i don't know i i i think he seems like
a pretty grounded vet
uh he's he's been around for a while but
he hasn't really
he's usually pretty well accounted for
and there's plenty of times where it
would have really benefited him to
shape-shift into someone else and he
didn't
so i'm gonna say two out of five screw
uncertain for for jimmy rhodey
boom you looking for this uh now let's
talk about hawkeye clint
barton let's take a look at this guy he
is a skilled assassin with a covert
globetrotting
skill set pretty good motive for a
scroll to want to assimilate into that
guy
and you could also argue well he was
under house arrest for a while maybe he
wanted to have a
scroll sit in for him as he continues
avenging on secret missions
without the ankle monitor yeah not all
these motives are airtight
i'm just going to tell you that he just
needed a babysitter
yeah yeah he's just for babysitting it's
a completely valid excuse to have a
double
now the evidence would be there was that
that line of avengers where he goes
you and i remember budapest very
differently he doesn't understand
how natasha describes this event as
budapest maybe because he wasn't there
yeah also i'll say it was interesting
how he was so willing to sacrifice
himself and end game
sure out of love for natasha but also he
had a family he had a chance to get his
family back that was driving him so much
why would he now be okay with like well
i'm gonna bring my family back but i'm
not gonna see them
yeah i don't know i don't know if i were
his kid i'd be pissed
yeah i'd be like wait he did what why
didn't he let that
family-less spy jump over um also clint
understands the properties of the
tesseract surprising fury in a scene
at the beginning of avengers right he
goes uh uh
some it must be activated from the other
side and nick fury's like
wait how do you know how the tesseract
works he's like it's a door right door's
open for both sides
right all right bad writing maybe
but we're gonna score him two out of
five scrun certain
pretty low okay natasha romanov the
black widow uh
she is deceased in the current timeline
but we will see her in
like an earlier period in history in the
black widow film she is a super spy
she's got connections to shield
connections in uh stark industries
connections with the russians
she's already a master in disguise and
maybe because she's got this
complicated red room history no one
would look deeper into this dark history
they would just assume it's kgb related
but i realized it could also be
extraterrestrial
maybe one thing that i always found
interesting is nick fury at the end of
age of ultron said hey
uh we're trying to track hulk but uh we
saw this jet crash in the middle of the
ocean we haven't been able to identify
it
right and she never looks into it right
of course
it's not hulk he's over on sakaar so
what the hell was that
ship and why wasn't natasha freaked out
about it maybe because it was a scroll
ship
and she just just covering it up yeah
yeah i'll look into it
as i'm actively tearing up this report
the evidence um now there's also an
interesting little moment and game where
she claimed to not know her father was
named ivan
on vermeer she's like oh i never knew my
father despite the same writers and
directors of that movie
had a deleted scene in civil war where
she claimed to have found her parents
graves
years earlier how do you know to your
parents graves if they're unmarked she
didn't say they were unmarked she just
said they were in this random spot
like you gotta assume a name was on the
grave or she would have to know their
their names in order to find those
graves but
yeah the the big issue is when we saw
her die for the brief
moment that the camera lingered on her
she did not turn back into a scroll
right so that
seems to be pretty pretty safe but there
might be more to this story i'm still
gonna leave her at two out of five
scrunch certain because there still
might be
another natasha out there which brings
us to our next character who i think
might be more likely a skrull yelena
bilova
for excuse character in the upcoming
black widow she is also a spy operative
for all the reasons why natasha romanov
could be a scroll
so as elena belova possibly would now
something weird is going on with elena
in the black widow trailer footage
she's got some there's like a face swap
surgery going on that we spotted where
there's like a marker line drawn around
her face
and she's strapped down to like a
surgeon table she is wearing the same
vest in this movie that natasha later
shows up wearing an infinity war
huh so think about it if she were a
scroll she wouldn't need to surgically
face swap she could just go crazy
but you could imagine a scenario where
skrull yelena
poses as natasha as scarlett johansson
to take her place
in infinity war in an end game that's
the
character we saw meanwhile human natasha
gets
elena's face surgically implanted on
hers
and she lives on as florence pugh in the
mcu
same character different actress who's
not as expensive as scarlett johansson
oh my god so that's it's a little crazy
i just think there's a lot of strange
inconsistencies maybe after black wood
eventually comes out we'll come back to
this be like this it's crazy but i'm
going to rate elena bulova as three out
of five
scroll suspicious that is a
pretty insane theory but i will i go i'm
i'm on
i totally agree i just can't think of
like other reasons why they would show
us in the trailer this weird
um a surgeon line around her face
right something is going on and there is
a comic where they do get face swapped
that's
surgically face there's a face off oh no
yeah eric i was gonna say that movie is
called face off that's not
yup yup so it's possible it's possible
okay let's talk about sharon
carter so sharon carter is a very high
ranking post hydra shield agent so it'd
be one thing this is before the hydra
reveal
but she's there after the hydra reveal
so we know
she's up there how did she survive that
why was she not sucked in
to the hydra conspiracy how did she rise
so far
up well maybe because she has another
allegiance
that of the scroll race and she's
connected with the avengers she's one of
these periphery characters and she's
sneaky she lied to steve at least once
and the endgame screenwriters wanted to
show her in a failing relationship with
steve during the blip
that was scrapped from endgame but you
know if you think about it
marvel might be planning something more
for this character as a result of that
i just think she like happy hogan she
would be a really cool
time candidate that no one would like
that an eye that would be a good like
chess piece to have in the game
yeah oh for sure so three out of five
squirrel suspicious skills
all right let's move on to some very
inconsistent
interesting candidates bruce banner hulk
right so what would be the motive to
impersonate bruce banner well
you might be useful to impersonate the
most powerful rage monster
on the planet but also alternatively
maybe there's like a partnership that
bruce has where he
has a scroll double fights his battles
as hulk for him
while he can continue on to try to reach
this like stasis
you know that makes sense like you could
still have the scroll identity
with like the classic hulk identity
rather than like end game kind of
ending his arc it seems yeah it's reason
i bring him up now is
uh banner just has a lot explaining to
do so he should not have remembered hulk
memories in infinity war that's the
whole point when he goes into hulk he
blacks out he doesn't remember anything
from that time period and ragnarok he's
like wait what year is it
he was it was like he was in the back
room of a party didn't know what was
going on but infinity war he knew all
about thanos it's like he was who
was in the front row of whatever was
going on there also
hulk should not have lost a fist fight
against thanos and infinity war hulk
never loses a fight he just gets angrier
and madder and he keeps fighting fighty
fighting forever
also uh smart hulk is just like kind of
a bizarre identity that
never does anything truly hulk like an
endgame
yeah he absorbs the blast of the
infinity stones but like he never
becomes he never hulks
he never goes crazy you never rage
monsters it seems like someone who's
like impersonating
the hulk it's awkward for him and i'll
also say despite of all the avengers
he's been like the least point of view
character just because marvel doesn't
fully own the rights to the hulk
they can't do just like another hulk
movie uh without working with universal
so it paints marvel in a corner where
they're kind of running out of things to
do with them
he might be like the most high-profile
avenger that they could reveal as a
scroll
and and do interesting things with i can
see this one just because he was
so different in endgame compared to like
how he behaved in his abilities in
previous movies it's like
yeah and and everybody you know kind of
complained about that a little bit and
this would explain it
yeah this could be one very interesting
explanation that could give you a way to
reset the character so i'm gonna rate
bruce banner four out of five
scroll cities and then move on to a
character i think is
a very likely candidate secretary
thaddeus thunderbolt ross william hurt's
character
his motive well he is the united states
secretary of state he
represents the government in these
movies ever since president matthew
ellis
never really shows up after iron man 3.
ready sir what do you mean
they just kind of use ross as the
representative of the government
you can imagine he would want to reign
in all the variable threats on this
planet possible collateral damage with
the sokovia courts
gives them more control make an and you
know
alien species probably get to earth and
they're like wait you have
a 100 something different governments
you don't have like a world government
that's
that's supreme that that doesn't make
sense well you must constantly be at war
with each other oh you are
so this is like a movement towards you
know that kind of like
globalism anytime there's globalism
there's there might be some conspiracy
involved there
also in the secret of ancient comics
yeah political figures are impersonated
at one point you see someone who looks
like obama
and someone who looks like mccain who
are scrolls who are like everything's
fine
yeah so this guy's got to be a scroll
the biggest evidence being he
disappeared for several years after a
mysterious heart attack that he says
gave him perspective
yeah right nobody gains perspective
after a heart attack idiot
no i will say if something fishy is
going on with ross
i hope that it's more likely that he's
like gonna become red hulk and that's
the big story there
rather than him be a scroll but like why
not both
he could be both a scroll and then also
like but really
my other self was becoming red hulk so
i'm gonna rate secretary ross
four out of five scroll sidious scroll
sidious he can have it all he can do
both
he can do both um and this brings us to
our final name on the list someone who
i think is very very likely a scroll and
i might be a little disappointed they
don't make him a scroll
howard stark really
wow so here's my reasoning for this a
lot of my argument for tony stark being
a scroll was really based on howard
stark's mysterious backstory
what would the motive be well i could
imagine back in the early 20th century
the scrolls identifying planet earth and
sending a scout
to this planet to check it out as a
possible scroll refuge option
and then while he's there he enriches
its technology
with seemingly god-given divine insight
to how to uh create the ark reactor
design
like this guy there's something off
about him
he had early access to the tesseract but
for some
mysterious reason he handed it off to
marvel to annette benny wendy lawson to
help the squirrel build a light speed
engine
why would he do that why would he be
okay with it being
floated up to orbit if he didn't have
some kind of connection or relationship
there
we also know he's been a pretty absent
father to tony he was
would tony uh talk to him in endgame um
howard stark was just kind of like
confused about the details of pregnancy
he's like i'm just gonna give her
sauerkraut
she might be this far along i don't know
how humans procreate yeah really
we poop out eggs and then we we let
birds watch over them for you i don't
know how squirrels procreate i just
assume it's
it's not mammalian at all it's like it's
like snakes yeah it's like stinks
the male rattlers perform a weird ritual
of one upsmanship
so yeah i just think howard stark is
even more of a genius than tony stark so
much of tony stark's genius comes
directly from howard
howard stark was able to ingeniously
design the city of tomorrow
to have an atomic structure that he
probably based on his experimentation
with infinity stone tech
also i'll say that you know when he died
in the flashback in 1991
in civil war we didn't see him revert to
a scroll of course right the camera
also didn't linger on his final breaths
we saw him like get his head slammed
and then you know because the pg-13
movie you're going to see his like face
h is not green so i think it is
very very likely that howard stark is a
scroll or has been
or has more of a historical connection
based off some of the weird things we've
been told about his history
so i'm gonna reach out here and say five
out of five howard stark
scrun firm wow i actually
really like that not because it's like
oh
you know i just want to have a scroll be
somewhere formative
it actually would explain a lot of stuff
yeah and like it's no one would be
offended by that if howard star if
you've got john slattery back in there
he'd be like what is this sure i'll do
it yeah and then noah would be like way
hold on because he's been kind of off
screen for most of these movies yeah
that'd be great and there's also a
really weird thing in age of ultron that
i'm just remembering
now when ultron was going through all
the database there's this weird shot
of of howard stark in the 50s where they
blurred
john flattery uh with the other guy who
played him
into one like face mash thing that kind
of looks like he's shape-shifting a
little bit
it's like the mid-animorphs thing you
know both
overlaid blurred into each other there
there's some scroll-spirity stuff going
on there
so in summation uh marina i would say at
least one of the characters we mentioned
in the mcu will be revealed as a scroll
hopefully several of them
and it's it's likely to be someone who
knows more than they let on someone who
ranks high in the government or society
uh especially a post hydra mcu
and someone who is important but someone
who won't piss off everyone if they were
to be revealed as a scroll so i think
people like howard stark secretary ross
sharon carter
sound like the solid options in my book
now i didn't mention the guardians of
the galaxy the asgardians
anybody who i considered to be on the
rocket path go watch that video that i
talked about
um just because they're already
absurdist like they're already
extraterrestrials the point of secret
invasion is to reveal how these simple
humans that you've trusted all this time
are actually sneaky green aliens so like
it's not as fun when it's already a
green alien like amore turning into it
just
a different green alien you can't pull
the rug out and then pull the floor out
right right or you pull out the rug and
then you just keep them on the rug
it's like oh you just gotta drag me
around on this rug all right fine i'm
still standing all right before we move
on to some bite-sized questions just
want to give a quick reminder that you
can help support this channel by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
new rockstars and the biggest benefit of
this is you get access to our official
exclusive discord server that's where we
do all of our
real deep dive theory discussion we
we've met some of uh
our like greatest supporters amazing
people who are part of this community
it's like
i've i've been part of other discord
servers i don't know if you felt this
way marina if you
explore this world it can be kind of
scary disgruntled yeah
so it's not always like a safe space but
like ours is a very supportive
friendly uh group of people and i love
all of them
and it's fun to re-watch these movies
with them in the room we just did that
with ailey and i was like
this is one of my favorite screenings of
alien that i've done with these discord
folks fun
so again if you want to join that
discord you have to be a patron
at any patron tier level obviously it
would help us out if you can give more
but if you can't get that much
we'll take whatever you can give us at
patreon.com new rockstars
the highest level of uh patron gets to
control eric's level of oxygen
all right all right back back all right
let's move on to some bite-sized
questions marina is going to take these
you ready marina
yeah all right number one uh oliver on
twitter asked how does thor
still have his powers after asgard was
destroyed right so
you would think that once asgard is
destroyed that things wouldn't work
anymore right but
odin said in ragnarok asgard is not a
place
it's a people and a peephole it's
a peep huh why is he irish it's a pee
pee but
it's because you don't
so we find out then that thor's powers
are not bound to the physical structure
of asgard just like
the people are don't have to stay on
that planet they don't just disappear
they're portable he's portable the
powers are portable
so after ragnarok was destroyed heimdall
prayed to the all fathers to summon the
bifrost if you remember
in infinity war and the bifrost
continues to function just fine via
stormbreaker so
we see it work without asgard anyway
and thor is the god of thunder and
asgard is wherever the asgardian people
currently reside
so it's not like thunder just stops
working just because there's no planet
so he can take his powers anywhere as
long as he's with his people
and that his people are somewhere
surviving then
he has his powers and he's still
connected to that source that's right
that's right now presumably
if uh if all the other asgardians did
die
thor if he was the only survivor i don't
know i guess
he still is asgard he still is a people
so
if thor was the only survivor he might
probably yeah it's like
uh fern gully like as long as there's
one
left you know there's no there's one
there's
that's beautiful i'm so glad we got
poured golly in on this oh
gravity works
i love it all right uh moving on to our
next question colonel hogan on discord
asks
when exactly was edith developed and
named so tony wore edith like
sunglasses in infinity war it was just
2018.
but he has had satellite linked ai
interfaces as early as age of ultron
which is 2015.
so after jarvis becomes vision in age of
ultron tony
upgrades to friday which suggests that
he has sort of like several alternate
versions
of operating systems sort of like ready
to go ready to plug in
so edith was a program he probably
already had invented some
sometime between 2018 and 2023 but he
didn't
name it edith until he anticipated his
possible death
and end game which is in 2023 um around
when he recorded
the goodbye message for pepper and
morgan
yeah that makes sense because it's even
dead i'm the hero right
exactly he would need to in order to
anticipate the dead part
it must be around the time where he's
like okay i might die
which is 20 23. so sometime between
those two years
yeah he had that ai he had all the
technology in place for
for years and years years earlier but he
didn't like codify it as edith until
right before
that final battle knitting which is cute
because he just has a bunch of like
um helpful ai people just sitting around
waiting to be named
that's right that's right and there was
one there was like one where it was like
the big hero 6 thing
in age of ultron and there was like a
chip there's like oh the big hair sticks
so he has like all kinds of ones with
all kinds of names that i'm excited to
see hopefully in the future
all right we have time for one more
question from our box of scraps
of scraps i wrote it on this receipt
here oh my god
well i don't have access to our po box
and any someone else has a key
um all right cvs receipt yes it is
pull it run that back
let's enhance it
this question is what social media faux
pas
do you regret i got a couple stories i
think on this oh my gosh
okay so before i started doing new rock
stars uh with you guys
i had like probably literally 11
followers
on everything and um i don't know if
it's a social media faux pas
but i don't change the way that i
run my social media even though i have
all these followers from new rock stars
who probably nor
should you you should stay true to your
it's good that you well it's
like i just know that everybody's like
where's star trek where's bossy like
where's [ __ ]
like all that stuff and it's like
exclusively like social justice
like oh sure yeah content and political
posting like very very leftist postings
and i'm just like
every person who follows me i feel like
being like i'm sorry
get anything
yeah yeah i i get it like i you know
marina and i
met doing improv and comedy at a theater
and
like that so my account was just like me
trying to like get comedians to retweet
my jokes
and every once in a while i'll still try
to do that with a hot take and people
are like
why aren't you working on spider-man
oh right oh right i end every video with
like well i just finished that wolverine
theory follow me on twitter so everyone
that's why they follow me everybody's
just like get back to work
yeah yeah i have gotten that um
i'll say my faux pas story i i have
definitely i don't know if you've
had this before i have accidentally
allowed myself to get
uh triggered by trolls you know
that's exactly what they want the
exactly oh yeah you're feeding them
and then i get into it i've gotten into
it for sure yeah
i i can't let go back and forth so
actually yeah so this connects
marina and i used to perform at um i o
west this is
theater in hollywood r.i.p it
it was a great community but it was just
like it suffered from
um past managers who just ran it into
the ground
and in the last couple years of it our
friends took over the theater
um as like the local management but it
was just too little too late i think and
they were great one of them was on
screen producer zach huddleston uh who
was
such a fantastic administrator and had
such big ideas
but the owners in chicago just pulled
the plug which is so unfair
they did it with like 11 days notice it
broke all of our hearts but uh
throughout those final years you know we
all love the community but a lot of us
felt that disillusionment
oh yeah definitely we love the people
there but we all kind of like
looking around like yeah yeah um
so one of the things that came out of
this was a twitter account called the
improv guru
what is this tell me okay the improv
guru it's his parody
uh twitter account that's actually
involved in this whole other thing
and it's super funny he uh he was like
anonymous it was someone in the
community
was posting like uh just trolling
people like our the owner sean halpern
in chicago
matt besser at ucb all these different
teachers it was just kind of making fun
of
the weird culti culture of improv that's
so funny
and how it's like so self-serious but
yeah
toxic in other ways and like because it
was anonymous this person would be
so like brutal the gut yeah
yeah and i loved it i thought it was so
funny
um and then when i o closed
improv guru did what he always did
making fun of everyone
and at the time i was so hurt by iowa
closing
like that's you know where i met all the
people all my friends
i was losing my clubhouse and i just
could not take a joke i could not take a
joke
so he said he i can't remember what it
was he tweeted something like
um io oh so sad to see io closing
um nice to see these final shows have
full houses
maybe if they pack the houses while the
theater was
still open it wouldn't have closed or
something that's that's pretty good
actually
very true very very true but at the time
like
there was he was kind of like dormant
for a while but then i o closed and it
was like
every day a new tweet and to me it felt
like you're just dancing on the grave
i couldn't take it i couldn't take it
marina what did you do
i responded because here's the deal i
knew who this was
i knew who this person was what a twist
and i knew him one of the funniest
improvisers
from chicago i'm not you can look him up
if you want he's not a bad guy
he's really really funny um and every
interaction i had with him face to face
super nice yeah but um but he's
anonymous and i knew him as like a
teacher and he's one of the people who
was running the training center for a
while
and i at the time i was kind of blaming
everyone from the old leadership
in my mind he was one of the guys who
like yeah like everyone at i o just gave
jobs to his friends didn't really care
about the business end of it
yeah and like in my mind i'm like dude
you might have you caused this theater
yeah you helped drive it into the ground
and now you're dancing on it
yeah you yeah um so i got so mad and
then i called him out
which big mistake because
he's just he's just trolling so he just
responds back in jest
and then i look in all of his chicago
friends which by the way iowa chicago at
the time
they were so happy to see ios club they
were happy
to dance on that great yeah so when they
see their buddy from chicago
[ __ ] on the iowa west community
they're like yup yup yup and they loved
it and they loved seeing someone like me
some unfunny nerd from ios take it too
seriously
so i went back and forth and back and
forth for a while and then uh he totally
he as you can it's like trying to heckle
one of the funniest comedians yeah
even if you're like you're right and
you're taking offense to the joke
you're in the wrong place yeah you're
not gonna win yeah and he trounced me he
totally trounced me
and like sometime later i went back and
i was like tail between the legs i just
deleted the tweets
you know what eric if you want to revive
that thread
i will be on your side and we will take
that [ __ ] down
let's get on twitter let's get on
twitter right now
because here's the deal it's like the
world does need it there are some
really weird things in the improv
community that definitely need purity
i think a lot of comedians can't take
criticism and especially a lot of people
in improv because we're like
artists trying to change the world with
our yes andy
yeah and there are a lot of like toxic
people in that community that he
he savaged that he he destroyed it was
so great to
go after him so i don't want him to stop
it i wanted to keep doing what he's
doing
he turned it into he turned his twitter
persona into like a short film
that was really good so like at the end
of the day he was right to win
and it taught me a valuable lesson like
trolls are going to troll
just let them do their toes are going to
troll that's true
the the other lesson is though if you
come for
eric boss on twitter
i thought you said if you comfort eric
volkswagen you do with me
you only give him hell i'm the only one
don't you cuddle this snowflake he's
mine
that's even better that's better that's
better well that is our show
marina it's been so great to relive old
times with you
and to go through all these scroll
options yes
i'm going to watch your twitter twitter
now if anybody comes for you i'll just
get out for all of you watching thank
you so much for sending in questions
and a reminder yeah join our discord be
coming to patreon at patreon.com slash
new rockstars you can also get an audio
version of the show by subscribing to
rockstar's big question wherever you eat
your podcast
send us your big questions on twitter
using the hashtag bigquestion or by
mailing us at our po box do you follow
me eddie of osmo
marina and marina mastros and follow new
rockstars on social subscribe here on
youtube to get too much information all
stuff you care about
and uh stick around after the credits
[Music]
oh